We're definitely living in a golden time for memory research
We're really fortunate because we're really standing on the shoulders of giants
But unlike these sort of real pioneers
Lashley, Hebb, even Kandel
we now have some tools available
that allows us to really probe the brain in new ways.
I think it's very tempting to think of memory
as a very sort of high fidelity record of events we experience
but there's so much like a video recording
but it turns out that's not the case.
All these things make us what we are
these interesting sort of bits of knowledge we have
are the aspects of life which we're interested in
but to some extent they are not that useful
but and it may be if you remember too much of that stuff
it tells me they'll get in the way of having an efficient memory system.
So it's not as if we're coming up with incredibly new theories
but what we're doing is we're testing some age-old theories that have been out there
and we can actually test them now using a pretty cool scientific methods.